[Musique]
chaque matin dans les écuries du cadre
noir c'est le même rituel
un ballet où chaque geste se répète les
soigneurs sont à la fois l'aide
indispensable des écuyers et les
gardiens du bien-être des chevaux
philippe et le soigneur de deux longs
comme l'acteur voilà après je connais
pas monsieur delon mais je connais bien
mon cheval de l'eau de long le cheval
est une gravure de mode forcément il a 9
ans le bel âge pour participer à la
prestigieuse reprise des écuyers nous
notre objectif c'est vraiment les avoir
en confiant serein détendu et après au
travail ils seront en action et sera en
action comme là ils vivent à savoir il
sait que je vais me préparer gentiment
il va se mettre dans la situation mais
l'a pour l'instant
le but c'est de l'avoir toujours en
douceur la priorité c'est une confiance
entre le cheval et nous et c'est ce
qu'on veut avoir la simplicité pas des
choses très c'est quoi ça c'est la
priorité
benoît et le cavalier attitré de deux
longs à 27 ans il y a seulement trois
ans qu'il est passé en noir selon
l'expression consacrée des toujours
qu'on n'ait pas nommé écuyer mais on le
devient donc il ya encore du travail à
faire pour l'instant j'arrive à faire du
gala avec des chevaux qui ont été
dressés par d'autres mais maintenant
c'est à moi d'en dresser points pour
faire du gala avec les chevaux que
j'aimerais c'est moi même
mais
deux fois par semaine les hommes en noir
répètent leurs chorégraphies dans le
grand manège des années de travail sont
nécessaires pour que ces chevaux
parviennent à assimiler les bases du
dressage
les membres rassembler au maximum sous
le corps pour permettre l'élévation du
dos et de l'encolure
ensuite seulement ils commenceront à
effectuer des déplacements latéraux qui
ressemble tu as des pas de danse
chacun travaille non plus de manière
individuelle mais vraiment pour le
collectif pour que y ait un mouvement
d'ensemble beaux uniformes et donne
l'impression ya un seul corps qui
fonctionne
[Musique]
il ya tellement de choses à apprendre et
on a la chance d'être entouré par des
gens qui ont plus d'expérience que nous
qu'ils sont meilleurs que nous et ce
sera comme ça toute notre vie et
peut-être que si un jour on fait partie
des anciens ici ce sera à notre tour de
transmettre nouveau c'est cette forme de
transmission qui est passionnante ici à
l'école autrefois situé au coeur de
saumur les écuries du cadre noir ont
déménagé à une dizaine de kilomètres
dans les années 80 pour intégrer
l'immense domaine de l'institut du
cheval et de l'équitation
les cadres au temps des guerres
napoléoniennes et est dégradée chargé de
l'instruction des troupes à cheval
d'abord bleu marine leur uniforme
devient noir le terme cadre noir est
alors un nom d'usagé ne sera
officialisée qu'en 1986
aujourd'hui les 34 écuyers et les trois
écuyère effectue toujours des figures de
dressage hérité des techniques de guerre
il ya la courbette au cheval se met
debout sur ses postérieur qui servent à
impressionner l'ennemi ou pour celui qui
est à cheval à se dégager d'une mêlée
avec des fantassins à des pics tout ça
et puis il ya la cabriole ou cheval à
commencent à s'élever du sol sur ces
postérieur ensuite ils dégagent les
postérieurs et donc ça permettait aux un
officier qui était pris de s'échapper
d'abord vers le haut et ensuite d'éviter
la mêlée et peut-être de sauver sa peau
la bibliothèque recèle quelques trésors
comme ce livre de cavalerie de 1733
aujourd'hui le cadre noir est un corps
de cavaliers d'élite qui a dû évoluer
pour survivre voire laisser partir un
patrimoine comme ça ça serait stupide
parce que d'une part il existe nulle
part ailleurs
et en plus c'est une référence dans le
monde entier et si ce n'était pas le cas
et bien tout simplement l'unesco fin
quand ils ont inscrit l'équitation de
tradition française sur la liste du
patrimoine culturel immatériel de
l'humanité
elle l'aurait pas fait le cadre noir est
désormais une institution civile
mais sept militaires font toujours
partie de l'effectif
le colonel patrick tesse rinck et depuis
trois ans l'écuyer en chef surnommé
grand dieu en référence aux écuyers qui
sont appelés dieu par leurs élèves
il participe aussi au gala avec sa
fidèle jument rendez vous
ce que j'apprécie cette communication je
peux avoir avec lui et puis vers l'est
sera le moment pas on se plaît à dire
aussi que c'est pas un courtisan
elle ne sait pas que je suis qui en chef
auquel elle peut me me virer du jour au
lendemain
non non je plaisante mais voilà il ya je
pense est voilà cette authenticité de
dans le rapport et qui a aussi ses leur
sensibilité qui est con con
sous-estiment toujours depuis quarante
cinq ans que je monte à cheval eux
chaque fois je me dis je en encore
sais-je encore sous-estimé cette
capacité qu'ils ont d'eux
d'absorber y compris nos émotions
[Musique]
près de 300 chevaux vivent sur le site
au sein duquel est intégré le cadre noir
toutes les six semaines environ ils
doivent passer par la maréchalerie pour
être repéré une maréchalerie qui peut
accueillir jusqu'à six chevaux en même
temps on essaie de fut d'avoir une
figure assez longue de façon à prolonger
à soulager des talons est ce que je
conçois et un bowling du pied de façon à
ce que les locomotion la plus
performante
[Musique]
et surtout aux bruits que l'on va savoir
si on est vraiment dans les parties dans
la paroisse donc la partie nord du pays
ou dans les parties vivante si on
mélange est parti vivant là c'est un peu
plus problématique parce que on touche
au à la partie depuis donc pour isa
server pas de pied pas de cheval
c'est l'un des principes de base que
doit apprendre tout cavalier qui veut
respecter sa monture retour aux écuries
nathalie la soigneuse prépare que nos
pour une répétition de la reprise des
sauteurs un langage invisible relie la
jeune femme à l'animal au comportement
on voit tout de suite à quel cheval en
affaires et lui il ressent aussi très
bien
il nous recevoir sens très bien notre
comportement ainsi il voit bien si
l'accord confiant sur quoi ils échouent
ils savent tout de suite je ça parce que
ça passe pas mais ils savent tout de
suite avant le s'est tout de suite
couché keno et la monture de mathieu van
landeghem écuyer au cadre noir depuis
dix ans et aussi compétiteur de haut
niveau en sport équestre dans la
discipline du concours complet ce qui
est sympa par rapport à la
au concours complet c'est qu'on est en
groupe il ya l'aspect collectif donc on
compare on se compare souvent un petit
peu alors peut-être faire sourire mais
une équipe de rugby parce que il ya cet
aspect un peu pas que comme ça chez les
sauteurs un peu voilà on à la troisième
mi-temps général aussi donc tout va bien
et on prépare à un doublé avec une
transition pas l'hymne du milieu
[Musique]
la reprise des sauteurs et le moment
fort des galas du cadre noir
les chevaux sont dressés durant cinq à
six ans pour effectuer des sauts
particulier hérité des combats où les
soldats devaient se servir de leur
monture pour attaquer ou se protéger de
l'ennemi pour mathieu l'exercice est
complémentaire de ce qu'il pratique en
compétition pour trouver un petit peu
cet aspect qu'on a dans la compétition
devant les ford voilà de devoir se
donner de s'investir et sortir des beaux
mouvements en piste c'est quelque chose
qui nous tient à coeur à tous
café comme un peu comme dans les
tribunes ça ça se passe de sorcier un
sorcier
on peut parler de sorcier mais c'est
voilà c'est un savoir qui se transmet
oralement par les oralement et de façon
pratique les heures d'entraînement et on
le pratique sous l'oeil du maître de
manège que là et qui veille à ce que les
choses soient de façon classique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la grande série du cadre noir
philippe le soigneur grèce régulièrement
le cuir débridée des selles
chaque cheval dispose de son matériel
particulier celui des représentations et
celui qui sert au travail de tous les
jours ça la salle de deux piquets elles
font un petit peu leur poids alors on
n'a pas du tout d'être signé par contre
là il en tenue de travail en noir
ici nous étions en gala on serait en
blanc le choeur fabriqués par les
bourrelier du cadre est un héritage
militaire qui ornent uniquement le
poitras et des sauteurs et ce matériel
prestigieux est aussi le symbole d'une
histoire séculaire céleri et eyal gala
donc oui c'est une présente à ses fins
et la fierté de notre de notre travail
parce que c'est notre métier et puis
c'est l'image qu'on présente à
l'extérieur
cette équitation française elle a quand
même pour grands principes surtout
l'élégance la discrétion des aides
certaine aisance avec le cheval de selle
confort qu'ils aient confiance c'est un
travail d'équipé
donc à nous de les observer les
respecter aussi quoi
[Musique]
si on fait ce métier là c'est pour les
chevaux et avec les chevaux et c'est ça
qu'il faut jamais oublier
[Musique]
au dessus du temps et des modes il règne
au cadre noir comme un parfum d'éternité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]